komplett bescheuert ich hätte nicht auf
zu rennen mit seinen kollegen hinterher
ganz ehrlich die stück schalter
los los leute herzlich willkommen zu
einer kleinen minecraft party mit herz
places widmen und mit ferry um pvp auch
bekommen wir wollten ob unter dem namen
ver di um pvp ja dass meine kräfte die
man so unter mir und wir legen nicht
mitgemacht dieses spiel
ich bin ja ja ja ja alle acht sekunden
dann gehen wir ins nächste mini game
moya ist der countdown und ich glaube
jetzt müsse das ampel spiel kommen wir
nicht umhin
bisher gibt es eine feste reihenfolge
was wirklich aus stellen ob ich denke
nein ich bin nicht tot aber das ist das
integrieren und plattform den routing
ein blau grün rot auf grün und da darf
ich das letzte mal gewonnen
ich hab einfach überall drauf ja ich
glaube mal so lässig am rad ist gut mit
explodierenden locken
also bei mir ganz gut
nein ich bin zweiter geworden
das ist wieder jetzt so wie das bak
bekanntermaßen bisschen ja conti mal so
ein bisschen auf den fingern aber mir
läuft gut ja bei mir auch dem ist gut
dem ist gut ok ich dass ich glaube schon
ich glaube schon okay ich bin locker
durch die engsten passagen die es hier
gibt
und da ist die gute skk bis sich alle
nein warum löst auf mich zu bist du dumm
bei mir hat hat er angezeigt das ist der
blöcke werden
ich bin auch ich bin fitter geworden
youtube schoppel okay das jetzt so was
wie black pack 2 1 ausgefallen
ach was du das artikel leiter ich hab ja
ich hab's perfekt auf aufnahme wie du
einfach die selbst ein loch selbst und
verkäufer das denn ich bin werde ich
könnte natürlich auch überlegen sie aber
zu verpassen
nicht immer über diese hater fanboys
molzen so du bist weiter bis verkackt
aber bescheuert
du bist die ganze zeit hinterher ist man
kein leben und tod oder leben am leben
wir machen jetzt einen ganz kurzen
katzengleich und hielt das ist an sich
eine mega d
aber es gibt fast das werde ich gewinnen
laufen bei mir läuft was das ist so
verbuggt alte leute hört ihr hat gesehen
was passiert ist ich wurde einfach in
die kommentare ob es karten back war
oder ob ich auf dem mini gelaufen bin
weil ich darauf eingegangen gesehen aber
da muss man da muss man so tiere töten
schreibt kommentare doch mal die musste
hauen die mit dem pinken schrift
immerhin muss man die noch schlagen
alter die kuh geht so apfalter ohne sie
walter dieses dieser scheiß bagso das
dauert einfach ewig zwischen die zeit
zwischen huhn anvisieren und schlagen
und dann tatsächlich hund stirbt ist
etwas so lange müssen im boden fest auch
jetzt wieder
ja das ist ja geil
meine kleine chor ja meine kuh
aber vierter platz naja ich hab es am
ende trennen
ok ich muss mich hier sehr konzentrieren
weil letzte runde bin ich so ein
bisschen gefehlt muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen alter ich bin ja dass die
vergeltung
das ist natürlich die pussy variante die
wolltest du spielen aber ich bin ja noch
aber irgendwie ist es schwer sich dann
zurückzuhalten
doch es gibt noch einen anderen sterben
stirbt niemand
ok weniger immer wieder abgesprungen
alte wie schnell es geht weiter was ist
das ist echt gehindert des ultra heute
aber nie so viele teams gefunden mein
klar ich habe bis jetzt nur nicht so
viel sagen
mit fortune verzauberte mir kommen mehr
und mehr heraus
die anlage darf den verzauberten 6 aber
noch nicht
dritter alter alter schwede
das ist wieder die plattform aus einer
feier genau ist ein verletzt letzten
zweiter platz nicht mal nichts gewinnen
aufgezeigt wie packen den spielmodus
noch und ich versuche ihn zu holen
was danach kommen soll wenn er dieses
ampel spiel kommt wo man laufen muss und
stehen würde ich gern darauf nehmen dass
er okay also ins spiel kommt dann immer
dass damit auch junge welt erwartet wenn
ich danach nahm die bank extrem
schlanken tablet so viel chance das doch
gar nicht mehr was kleidung
jetzt gibt aber ganz schön ab hier am 5
natürlich würde die runde machen auch
hier kommt eine meiner arbeit und dann
los geht's mit dem spaß hier und ich mal
gucken dass ich mich hier nicht in den
verkauf dabei habe ich gerade aus der
box nein ich halte diese piste alter
luftwerte direkt hinterher
das kann doch nicht sein oh mein gott oh
mein gott jetzt aber auch bisschen
beschluss oder andere position
ja wir hätten sogar aufgenommen und dann
würde ich sagen macht's gut leute haut
rein die links von meinen mitspielern
herz place und während der beschreibung
und servus gemacht